[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody happy sunday yeah we're back
hopefully you're having a good uh you
know weekend
jenny's still sniffling a little bit i
don't maybe i'm developing
allergies in my old age i don't feel
like i'm sick or anything like that but
i do have a little bit of like a sinus
headache yeah you know what i'm saying
and i didn't drink much last night i had
one drink and i didn't even finish it i
think
i think i fell asleep at like 6 30
watching riff tracks i don't know what
it was
a little a little rubber thing fell off
my glasses again
i got more of them it might be in here
it's probably in here it's probably in
here hook you'll eat it if you leave it
around
she's just like well she does she goes
around she she goes around the carpet
she goes
yeah like that you can hear her
snuffling around the carpet and then she
finds some random [ __ ] she's like
okay i'll just eat this i don't know
what it is she's [ __ ] lint and stuff
you know all right we um
we're going to talk about the new creep
show season they can't
well it's the episode it's a season two
episode three right that's the new one
yeah we're going to talk about uh
the loved one we finished that movie
1965 yeah interesting movie
you want to talk about creep show first
yeah good night cause like i said i
don't wanna i don't wanna like spoil it
because like i said that's new
i'm not as worried about it with the
loved one because that's a really old
movie
but uh yeah so the latest creep show
okay i'm gonna say
that this one i liked it better i think
than the last episode
but the first story is way better than
the second story that's what i'm gonna
that's what i'm gonna say
so this one the first story is called
the right snuff yeah which i thought was
really funny
kind of a riff on uh 2001 a space
odyssey
a little bit uh i was i was actually
kind of impressed at
the um the production design and stuff
like that which
i you know the budget for the creep show
is not very high
so they actually do a lot of really good
work with not a lot of
uh you know not a lot of money which is
which is very admirable
yeah they kind of emulate 2001 a space
odyssey the sets the interiors and the
exterior shots pretty well
yeah i mean it looked really cool but
yeah there was even like some little
howl jokes and [ __ ] like that in the
background
but it's basically the story is like i
said i'm not going to spoil it or
anything but the story is there's two
astronauts their names are alex and ted
right one of them's
like the captain and one of them is
like the scientific genius he's invented
something that
what does it do it has like some kind of
it can warp gravity or yeah it's like a
gravity drive
yeah something like that so he's
invented that but the but the
pilot i guess his dad was the first dude
i don't know what year this is supposed
to be said but his
dad was a famous pilot too and he was
like the first guy to land on mars right
um so he's kind of like there's a lot of
stuff about him not being able to like
live up to his dad like he has kind of
flashbacks about his dad being like
you'll never be good enough and like all
that kind of stuff
but so then it turns out that um
that we have uh contacted aliens
and um so houston sends like the little
genius guy let's send a little genius
guy out to talk to the aliens
and uh the captain is not too happy
about it because he wants to be the guy
because he wants to go into the history
books
yeah as the guy that talked to the
aliens yeah now you do see the aliens
and you find out what happens but none
of that [ __ ] can be spoiled
um the acting was good the story was
pretty good
um the special effects when came to the
aliens were kind of cartoonish and
they're they're supposed to be it's a
tone yeah it was a very mars attack
like 50s which i liked i liked that they
pulled that off really well yeah it was
cool
that the story wasn't too
complicated you're not talking about our
ultra sophisticated story
but it's with the inside the tone of
creep show
it so it worked it was interesting yeah
you don't see a lot of sci-fi
stories on creep show yeah was this kind
of maybe was this the first one
yes one like only one i remember i can't
really think of it maybe there was or
just like just
because i i haven't watched the first
season in a while like i saw a couple of
the episodes the other day
is actually a lot like i mean you can
tell
2001 is what they're yeah that's kind of
what the inside of the ship looks like
that's what a lot of them yeah which
that's great the way they did that yeah
but the type of story that it is is it's
kind of more like something
out of the animated movie heavy metal
yeah
more like something like like the loch
nar story of the lagnard
the story of the loch ness yeah yeah
which i was hey if you guys haven't seen
[ __ ] heavy metal see heavy metal
we still haven't reviewed that maybe we
should do a matinee on that one of these
days because i keep putting it in the
in the poll for the retrospective and it
always keeps losing yeah that's a
forgotten classic
and some of the deleted stuff it's on
the blue right that's really cool we
should do heavy metal and fire and ice
on one thing because i think fire and
ice might be on tubie or it was last
time
yeah i gotta see fire and it's been a
long time i used to like it back in the
day but
i kind of have a feeling that maybe the
story really isn't there i'd have to see
it again
yeah let's see it again now the second
story on the creep show was called
sibling rivalry now this one was about a
teenage girl at high school
and it opens with her telling her i
guess it's the guidance counselor
played by molly ringwald y'all yeah i
was i was
very excited about it really cute she's
still good looking she looks
almost so i mean they made her look you
know like a mom like a guidance
counselor and this one like with the
hair and the kind of frumpy clothes and
stuff but it's like you could tell
still tell it was her name and then i
had the cougar look yeah i still hit
that
and she's not she's um i think she's
four or five years older than me
yeah she's my age yeah so she yeah
because like i said i think she was born
in 68 early 60s okay so
she's a little bit older than me yeah
she's a little bit older
she still looks really good but i love
that they made her the guidance
counselor in this
yeah so this is about a teenage girl and
she's telling the guidance counselor
that her brother is trying to kill her
and she's telling like this big rambling
kind of story about it
but so basically it's just kind of like
this story of
her relating that her brother is trying
to kill her
but then there's not a lot to it then
there's like a twist
uh which i can't really spoil i didn't
love this one
it was just okay it was this one was
okay it ran into the same problem
if you guys saw the uh the kind of
one-off animated one
the one that had survivor type and then
the other one was uh based on the joe
hill story
like tweeting what was it called
tweeting from the circus of the dead or
something
um anything that's narrated by
a teenage girl like in full-on [ __ ]
teenage girl mode like over the top
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to um yeah because after
because i was like i don't know maybe
teenage girls nowadays do talk like that
but i kind of feel like it's over
rot a little bit you know what i'm
saying um
i remember when they tried to be when
they tried to pretend like they were
teenagers in a story back in the 80s
they're like man but nobody talks like
that
yeah so and so i kind of feel like maybe
that's the case here you know what i'm
saying from my understanding those
teenagers up to date are pretty [ __ ]
dumb though they're probably yeah but
teenagers that are all here
i think they know that's kind of one of
the defining traits of a teenager
is that they think they're smarter than
everybody else but really they don't
know anything they don't know the [ __ ]
they're talking about right that's just
how that works
like i said [ __ ] i think that
aristotle was complaining about that
like thousands of years ago
[Laughter]
these damn teenagers get off my lawn
real mentally quick a lot of agility
good verbal dexterity
no wisdom just dumb well yeah because i
mean and you can't expect them to have
wisdom because they're not that old
like they don't have any life experience
yeah i mean once once you're
old like we are and life has like kicked
you in the ass a few times yeah your
perspective has changed
actually you don't really understand you
don't really get any
grasp over the game you didn't even know
it was a game until you got about 40.
and you guys see the game they're
playing yeah yeah mango said i enjoyed
the second story of the episode but it
took a bit of time to get going yeah i
think that's kind of what it's once it
got
going and uh you figured out what
what was going on uh it was good then
but
i think they could have done with a
little bit less of her talking
yeah because she kind of you know what i
mean yeah because i was
and even molly ringwald was kind of like
it was it was trying to go a little meta
because she's like can you please just
get to the point what you're talking
about like with your brother trying to
kill you and all this other kind of [ __ ]
but yeah so i definitely preferred the
first one uh the sci-fi one
uh but yeah this was another pretty
solid episode all around
so uh you know good job shutter we're
liking them so far
all right so uh do you want to talk
about
the loved one yeah we've been kind of
referring to this
uh a few times like on some of our
lashes and we finally got it
he got it on what dvd blu-ray on dvd
yeah it wasn't really worth
spending the extra ten dollars from for
blu-ray in a black and white movie
that you know had all the same features
and everything so i just got it in dvd
it looked good um this is a weird movie
and it is very weird this is the only
movie
that i knew of that was weird that jenny
had never heard of
i showed her this movie she said man i
can't believe i've never seen this movie
oh you know what no there was one more
brimstone and treacle
yeah you didn't know about that one
either didn't although i had seen some i
had seen some other movies and read some
other books by the same
author uh but i didn't know that one we
need to the one two brimstone
we do i really like that movie a lot
yeah was in it about a demon
i guess played by sting
yeah well we'll have to find that that's
that's a very weird movie tip
yeah but yeah so the loved one it came
out in 1965.
what ended up happening with this was
that evelyn hua
the british writer you know he wrote a
lot of satire and stuff like that he
also wrote brides had revisited which
has been adapted for
movies like a zillion times and i guess
back in the 40s
he got like a [ __ ] ton of money uh for
the rights to brides had revisited
even though none of the executives at
the studio had even read it
so he used that money to come over here
and uh he wanted to
kind of direct the movie or be like uh
you know he wanted to have control over
it they were like yeah no and then they
just said forget it and didn't do it
while he was in la like doing meetings
with that
he got kind of fascinated about with the
american funerary industry
the funeral industry and um decided to
write a
well first he wrote like a big long
article about it and then he turned it
into
a book uh called the loved one and that
is what this movie is based on and i
guess they tried to make this
a movie a couple of times i think even
uh what's his name that hung out with uh
salvador dali
uh louis vunwell yeah that's funny uh
he tried to make it too yeah because
there's a lot of absurdism in this
it is very absurdist this is along the
same lines as if you're into [ __ ] like
uh dr strangelove is very like dr
strangelove or like the magic christian
or like a lot of movies like that that
came out around that time that are real
kind of
satirical weird absurdist it's in that
kind of vein it's almost like more
british sense of humor obviously because
it was written
some of the characters are british too
and it was written by a brit and the um
and the screenwriters yeah and he's kind
of just experiencing kind of the
absurdism of california
of the 60s and the in the industries
the big corporate industries of the 60s
including like
the space industry and just everything
you know
yeah how everything is in hollywood you
know how third that is
it's just uh yeah it's it's a weird
flick
and it's very it's kind of goth in a way
it has a lot of goth [ __ ]
sensibilities to it it does yeah
um this british guy shows up
in uh california without really a pot to
piss in and no money
and he meets up with his uncle who's an
old hollywood queen
who's been working john gilgas this is a
star studded yeah yeah
everybody in this is a star and uh he's
got this recreation of a damn british
cottage that he lives in
inside hollywood and you know hollywood
was fake as [ __ ] back in the 60s it's
still fake
well it's not even there anymore i don't
think not as not in the form that it's
shown in this movie
and it's uh
it just shows the absurdism that was
going on inside hollywood
studios and this dude had been
his his uncle had been like a loyal
actor and employee for this studio for
like 35 [ __ ] years
and they basically fire him over nothing
and kind of kind of accuse him of being
a thief in a way on his way out the damn
door which he didn't steal the [ __ ]
painting yeah
then he goes home and commits suicide
and his young nephew finds him hanging
literally yes by his neck
all the british expats are in this
basically this group
run by the oldest most noble british men
and he's holding
all these british people to the british
standard he's
whether you like it or not you are
ambassadors of the [ __ ]
you know of the queen and all this kind
of [ __ ] they have to have
meetings they watch each other they
[ __ ] judge each other about what
their what what their jobs are and it's
just crazy
they make this kid sign over
all of his uncle's possessions
to like a foundation to have him buried
in style
in this place called whispering glades
which need to be buried there [ __ ]
cost hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of [ __ ] dollars
it's like this massive this massive
[ __ ] great
and it's got like all these sections and
neighborhoods like the falls of xanadu
the whispering glades and it's like a
theme park yeah
all right and it has the motif is
[ __ ] the motif of it is [ __ ] great
really all right
it's non-sectarian which in
in the american world that would mean
just generic
generic christian but
when it's generic christian in the
united states what you're talking about
is
like southern baptist and they look like
baptist ministers
and televangelists that's what
everything is kind of
the the the visual look is greek
mixed with i don't know the haunted
mansion from disneyland yeah a little
bit
some victorian highlights
it's staffed by all these hotties these
[ __ ] hottie goth chicks in these
weird
60s
flight attendant slash morticia adams
outfits it almost kind of looks like
maybe this is one of the things because
i remember the poster saying it's like
there's something in it to offend
everyone
and it's obviously it's not offensive by
today's standards but i can see how it
would have been offensive in 1965.
the outfits that a lot of the uh women
are wearing
whispering glades yeah they're really
cool they almost
i might be remembering this wrong but it
looks a little bit like um
jackie kennedy's morning outfit yeah
yeah it's kind of like
when her husband does kind of like
morticia adams slash
1960s flight attendants with veils
yeah weird [ __ ] hats and they're all
color
coordinated depending on what their rank
is and what their
jobs are and they all look kind of look
like
super models they look like models and
uh
they're constantly flirting at the guy
flirting with the guys and they don't
it's just as [ __ ] unfolds you find out
it's it's real irreverent you know what
i mean
they they act very
professional but that's not what's
actually going on at this place
it's it's yeah it's run by this reverend
played by jonathan winters yeah he plays
two roles in this he plays brothers yeah
he plays the reverend and his twin
brother
yeah and the twin brother owns the
[ __ ] cheap ass pet he runs the cheap
ass pet cemetery
the happier hunting happier hunting
ground it's all part of the [ __ ]
story
well he gets involved with uh you know
barry and his uncle and he gets a tour
and this place is [ __ ] amazing it is
amazing wherever you go they got the
damn
huge statues of the reverend and he's
and they press a button and a recording
of him [ __ ] booms out
he says all this magnificent crap you
know it's just
that yeah welcome to whispering glades
where you're you know for eternity your
soul
so he goes through the whole burying his
uncle thing and there's all these
different options
he's in it he's looking and he he's he
works there he's the one that shows you
all the costs yeah
there's a bunch and if and there's a
bunch of gay innuendo if you didn't
now that you know that liberace is gay i
i think they were in
the average person probably back in the
day probably didn't know that liberace
was gay
well insider people knew yeah people
knew
yeah remember when they had the damn sex
party yeah and
and all the generals the air force
generals are opening up the caskets
all the hot girls one general opens it
up and [ __ ] liberace comes out and
asked for a cigarette
that was some innuendo right there okay
it's just a great flick it's [ __ ]
weird um
but you got to say that when he gets
there when
uh the kid gets there his name is dennis
barlow by the way
in the movie he's played by robert
morris he meets this chick he meets this
chick who is a cosmetologist
for the dead yeah and her name is amy
fanatogenous yeah it has the french
spelling with the two e's
well she supposedly named after amy
semple macpherson
who was like a really famous in real
life she was a real famous uh
evangelist in the 20s and 30s yeah so
she's wearing this white
[ __ ] outfit this morning out she's a
beautician for the dead
yeah she does their faces and stuff
and uh she's cute as hell you know she's
a good looking
actress and she's just this very
innocent
very innocent [ __ ] kind of naive
idealistic goth
adjacent type 60s
chick i guess yeah she really believes
in
she believes in all this [ __ ] for real
yeah and all this stuff for real like
she doesn't
understand that that it's a business
that it's a business and that it's just
like a crass
corporate yeah she really actually
believes in
you know these people are for eternity
and she's super into her job
yeah so the so most of the movies about
this british guy
meets her and and he's falls in lust
worth her really and
he he's kind of like got a beatles
haircut he's kind of like a 60s cool guy
he doesn't have a pot to piss and no
money or anything
and he just tries to talk his way up
this chick's skirt through the whole
thing by using other people's poetry
book
but he doesn't realize it he's like
quoting like shakespeare's sonnets and
like robert herrick and stuff at her and
it's like no
when he shows up he doesn't know it but
she's she is already kind of in this
flirtation
flirtatious relationship with
a guy she works with who's he's about
50.
yeah he's like the head he's the head
mortician mortician yeah
and he's the name of his character is mr
joy boy played by rod steiger
yeah and he [ __ ] you know what i mean
he
he's a lot like her actually he's
another one that really believes this
stuff he believes in [ __ ] vows of
[ __ ] remember that he said i can't do
that i'm breaking my vow
yeah he's a true believer in the [ __ ]
too but he gets in between him and
[ __ ] it's a big kind of love triangle
mr joy boy finds out that [ __ ] the
dude's pilfering all this [ __ ] poetry
he tries to expose him
he's trying to get the girl they're both
trying to get it yeah it's like a love
triangle
they're both trying to get the girl
and then some crazy shit's going on
amy's right into this second
indian guru who's given her the advice
of which man to [ __ ] pick right
but it turns out it's just this dude
that works up the [ __ ] road at the
damn
at the newspaper he's just like an old
drunk drunk guy
look at this the ghoul from the
graveyard
he's one of those kind of guys
he thinks she's a nut when he finally
meets her in the bar he's like oh
look at you it's the ghoul from the
graveyard
there is so much crazy [ __ ] yeah we
haven't even mentioned
mr joy boy's mom yeah he lives with his
mom he's taking care of his mom
and all his role is just to take care of
his mama to feed her
she's [ __ ] morbidly obese he cooks
whole pigs for her
[ __ ] uh just piles food under when
he's not around
she dumps the refrigerator on herself
and just [ __ ] lays on the floor
and it's there's there's some underlying
messages there you know i mean he tells
amy that he had a dream that he
was cooking up all these lobsters for
and they were undercooked and she says
oh don't worry i'll eat him anyway so
she starts eating the raw lobsters and
the lobsters are eating
you know fought back and started eating
her and her and the lobsters are eating
each other and that was his that was his
nightmare
and there's a bunch of
i guess you could say moral lessons
amy was kind of you find out that amy is
she's just dedicated herself to this
funeral business that doesn't really
give a [ __ ] about her
okay and joy boy has kind of dedicated
himself to being a good son and
dedicated himself to taking care of his
mom and she doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about him either when he's not around
she's like oh yeah yeah
man she's kind of useless she just wants
the food she just wants the food
he's kind of given up his whole personal
life really to take care of his mom it's
kind of his mama's boy
um it's just
it it i don't want to spoil it because
if you guys haven't seen it
because i feel like a lot of people have
yeah it's the weird gym
i want to say too um we also didn't even
mention at the pet cemetery there's also
paul williams yeah plays a kid
yeah builds rockets right
he can build a rocket from scratch and
this is this is in a time when rocket
science was the [ __ ] top science
if you could build a rocket then you
were the [ __ ]
well back at whispering glades
um the guy who owns it played by
jonathan winters he's this mysterious
[ __ ] character that runs around in a
damn helicopter dressed in all black
with this [ __ ] hat and he's got this
assistant this this chick
i guess his assistant slash girlfriend
and she's just smoking hot i mean when
you see her you just she's
in like one of those funeral outfits
it's like a business suit with
glasses black glasses yeah she's got
really dark like sunglasses yeah and
this [ __ ] hat
like gentleman's videos she wasn't i
don't think she didn't say anything
she's just back there but
you kind of have the feeling that
that she's like kind of control not
controlling him but
that she's like his right hand man in a
way
yeah there was some kind of power
dynamic going on
um but wherever he was she was right
there taking notes and doing things i
guess it was like his main secretary is
his secretary
it's supposed to be but you could tell
it's his girlfriend
and uh
he he makes he's got his brother he
calls his brother out of retirement for
being a loser and puts him in charge of
the pet cemetery
yeah and while he's at the pet cemetery
his other
twin brother he's teaching
okay amy's boyfriend the british guy
goes to work for this pet cemetery
to try to make some kind of money to
impress amy but then it when amy finds
out he's working there she kind of
[ __ ]
she's [ __ ] flabbergasted because she
thinks barry and pets is [ __ ]
sacrilegious religious she's like a true
believer yeah she's very yeah but it's
not christianity
not really it's just her name is
amy thanatogenous yeah but they're
talking about thanatos
yeah the god of death yeah yeah and
she's she is kind of a morbid
kind of chick she lives on a house
that got condemned during construction
because they were building it on a slide
zone and it's someone overlooking l.a
she's living in it anyway tearing the
damn posters the the
off and when he walked in it didn't even
have walls that just had chicken wire
and stuff
and had all these beautiful chandeliers
and
stuff she got from the from the cemetery
i believe
the real chandeliers and statuary and
stuff
and he walks in there with her and the
thing starts going like it's going to
fall and he's like what the [ __ ]
about the slide zone isn't this going to
fall and she's like oh i suppose it will
and then she goes on the back she's
swinging
and the whole house is getting ready to
like fall off
and she says i don't care about things
that are practical i only surround
myself with things that are beautiful
which that's kind of like that's kind of
what that character was about
did anything to do with practicality it
was this fantasy idea of beauty
well she's a very wide-eyed naive
character but she's not but she's also a
really lovable kid yeah
just that she's totally blissfully
unaware of danger she's
like completely pure yeah and she
doesn't understand
that the world is not right yeah you
know what i mean so he's like completely
innocent
yeah and i think in the end when you
find out that i think mr joy boy was
kind of like the
other male representation of the of that
same character
they were different you know what i mean
and how they manifested but
they were kind of they were kind of peas
in a pod really
they were kind of like the only people
that weren't completely cynical they
weren't cynical right yeah actually
believed in what they were doing
um even though what they were doing was
basically self-destructive
yeah because they weren't aware of the
evil of other people
and i think that's really what it meant
yeah um
make a long story short too late
too late
the guy who owns whispering glades
decides that there's no
that they're going to run out of space
soon at the rate that they're filling
the place up and once that happens they
they won't be able to afford
for the overheads and the the business
will go bust
so the best course of action is to
change the cemetery
into a convalescent home yeah because
old people constantly appear every year
and it has a brisk
turnover so you wanted to turn it into a
futuristic
glass and stainless steel city of the
elderly you know
to launch them off into the [ __ ]
afterlife and [ __ ]
but he couldn't do it because there was
all those damn dead bodies on the
property
so um through his brother who has the
[ __ ] pet cemetery they find out that
they have a little kid that can make
rockets
rockets and they asked the kid how are
we going to get all these looking bodies
out of here and he
starts talking about the icbms that the
that the uh the air force has
so what's the guy's name the j what's
the jonathan leonardo's name that the
guy who owns whispering glade
is glenn were there something i think
was
reverend glenn it was something like it
was something i think it was glenn where
the
[ __ ] has all these air force generals
over and he applies them with booze and
women
to sell him icbms to launch all these
damn
dead people into orbit they were going
to be in a celestial orbit of eternity
and
his word knitted at least in a real
[ __ ] beautiful way
and uh [ __ ] i don't know if i should
spoil the end you should don't don't
yeah i can't spoil the end there's
because
it gets it gets pretty interesting but
it wraps up very quickly
i i thought there was more to it how it
ended
back we don't have all of the cultural
context um
because it was written for another
generation
and i think there were some certain
things that about it that were
very unusual to them but to us or just
that's like a normal thing
but not back in those days so we don't
have all the cultural context but it
still holds up
it holds up as a as a strange and
enjoyable movie
yeah it's just it's a very very weird
like i said if you're into dr
strangelove and stuff like that the only
thing that i didn't remember because we
saw this
uh several years ago and then i hadn't
seen it for a long time and then we got
it and we watched it
uh the other night or yesterday and
i had forgotten that a lot of it was
like dubbed over
yeah which is very weird like i know
that they dubbed some of jonathan
winter's lines because i think that they
changed one of the characters names like
in the middle so they had to dub him
over like him calling his brother
by the other name because i guess they
changed the character name i think they
also
robert morse or uh robert morris's
character
he plays like the main kid dennis barlow
i think that he's american and they
wanted him to be a brit
and i'd so i don't know if that's him
doing the british accent and then they
just dubbed it over or if they got
somebody else to dub him over
doing a british accent you know what i'm
saying because i'm not really sure what
his actual voice sounds like
yeah um but yeah a lot of it seemed
dubbed which which i thought was really
weird um ronnie mcdowell is in this too
yeah he's in it
so is uh milton burrow milton burl is in
it for for a second in like a really
weird scene
um james coburn is in it for a second
he's like the dude at the airport
he was it was like a cameo yeah i think
what made
the movie uh i think interesting for its
day
um that might be lost in translation for
to the average person is that this is
this is for a 60s audience and they're
showing a world in which
the military complexes can be corrupted
by
booze and women and that religion
and the funeral business are just kind
of irreverent
businesses like any other business yeah
and i think those were kind of
like nowadays we know that people yeah
so it's not a big deal and it doesn't
yeah it doesn't really offend it but
back in those days i think but in the
60s that's probably what he wrote
that was kind of a new concept right um
and uh the idea that some characters
believe in fake [ __ ] just wholeheartedly
that i think that was kind of
that might have been disturbing to them
back then because a lot of people
believed in a lot of fake [ __ ]
wholeheartedly back then
yeah you know i mean back then they
still believed in
evangelists evangelism yeah like that
was a real thing
then televangelists appeared eventually
yeah and then that kind of eroded
the credibility of evangelists
that's true you know pre all that like i
said i kind of feel like that's why it
was significant that her name
was uh was amy like the spell the french
way and she even says in the movie
that she was named after amy simple
mcpherson who like i said
was a very famous uh evangelist like in
the 20s and 30s
like one of the first ones like to gain
like nationwide yes that whole concept
of religion and death being a bit
in a corporate business being business i
think that yeah that bothered people
back then
yeah and in a lot of ways like i said
it's a funny movie it's a satire
um and just showing everyone behind the
scenes as just being these cynical
yeah kind of like yeah so i can see how
that would have been offensive in the
60s sure
because your father in the midst because
you find out a bunch of [ __ ] about glenn
worthy
she was holding glenworthy up to be like
a god-like
being you know who helped people achieve
peace in the afterlife that he was
ethical you know she didn't really say
anything about morality
she always mentioned ethics yeah and she
really didn't say anything about
jesus or christianity wasn't about that
they
took that element away she was kind of
like non-secretarian like a
scientologist
is what she was like yeah i mean it had
some of the trappings of christianity
yeah the physical trait and there was
there was one scene where a jewish
couple came in and wanted to buy
a plot and they were turned away yeah
they were just sent to another place
why don't you go over there you'd be
much happier yeah you know what i mean
so it was kind of christianity adjacent
yeah well actually uh there was more to
it now if you noticed that
when they asked him who the the loved
one that he was burying the british his
british uncle
they asked him what race he was and he
said
is he caucasian he goes well no he's
white he goes yeah
and they went and they said that's good
and then they were asking
right so to be married to be to be
buried at whispering glades you had to
be
an uh like a anglo-saxon protestant you
couldn't be jewish
yeah you couldn't be black yeah anything
like that you had to be
a wasp you had to be a wasp
you know which a lot of during that time
you know a lot of evangelistic
activity was very waspy yeah you know
it wasn't it didn't mean that you know
black people were banned or anything but
it just meant it
just attracted white that's kind of what
this was subverting
kind of making fun of making fun of it
right yeah which like i said i can see
how that in 1965 that would have been
yeah
offensively 65. the square 65 in some
areas like
certain certain um certain like country
clubs wouldn't allow jews
oh yeah i know that was pretty common
but it wasn't official
it was just that they made sure that uh
maybe you'd be happier somewhere else
yeah but that wasn't written down on the
down paperwork that would have been um
gauche yeah well i think it would have
been a straight up that might have been
a lawsuit
yeah yeah they didn't want anything they
had in other ways
everything was kind of like nudge nudge
wink yeah you're like
yeah which you know that's kind of what
they showed in this one like
right yeah i think you'd be much happier
at this other right whatever the other
cemetery
yeah he'll be buried with those people
yeah yeah
i had totally forgotten about them
asking about him being said caucasian
he's like no he's not caucasian
yeah they want to make sure he was white
there's so many weird weird scenes in
this i was just thinking of the scene of
mr joy boy like uh
doing john gielgud's face like trying to
get his facial expression right
he was dead you know what i mean and
he's like yeah going back like that and
then he looked that he'd have a
different expression
yeah mr joy boy was like
he didn't do what was he doing the
makeup or did thanotogenous do the
makeup
well yeah um i guess he he arranged the
arranged the face and dressed them and
dressed them and stuff and then she did
the makeup
yeah and he would flirt with her by
sending the bodies to her in certain
[ __ ] facial expressions and [ __ ]
yeah so that's how you make her smile
yeah yeah and then he'd go out there and
flirt with her and all the other [ __ ]
cosmetologists and [ __ ] and all the
other mortician girls
would be like giving her hate looks
because they were evidently uh
kind of vying for this guy he was they
were uh
it was like a cult and it was very um
very much a hierarchy of who had what
job
yeah how long they had been there and
were they an embalmer or not an embalmer
that kind of stuff
so these girls were actually going after
they were kind of vying for
joy boy they were jealous that she was
getting all the attention yeah
yeah well then she was gonna get because
he put in for her for promotion right
yeah she was gonna be like the first
list the first lady embalmer
yeah and she was very i'll be the first
lady yeah yeah yeah she was so excited
yeah oh
amazon has it you can live stream it i
think it's only 199 or 299.
you can livestream it i recommend it
it's a fun movie to watch
yeah like i said if you're into like a
lot of those weird 60s
yeah kind of movies um you know
and you haven't seen it because like i
said it's i feel like i hadn't seen it
and that's
unusual it's funny it has
it has some 60s hotties in it it has a
death theme
it's kind of gothic in in certain spots
uh a real irreverent in certain other
spots but it's just kind of a
not all of it translates to to today
but it's just kind of it it was kind of
eerie the movie
had a weird eeriness to it a little bit
yeah
a little bit strange it's just the only
thing um
you know the cinematography is beautiful
it's actually a hacksaw wexler did that
who's like i said he's one of
probably one of the most famous
cinematographers of all time um
but yeah the dubbing is a little weird
and the edit is a little weird
but other than that because like some of
the scenes sort of
end sort of abruptly which is kind of
strange but um
yeah other than that it's just it's just
like a bizarre
bizarre movie movie
you never can't tell what's going to
happen next true
yeah that's true it's just kind of like
one absurdist kind of
thing i mean there is a plot like you
know this happens because of this and
whatnot but then there's all kind of
these just weird
yeah these weird kind of stuff really i
can't really
uh there's no other real move there's no
other movie like this
not really like i said it kind of gives
me a vibe like some of those
trippy 60s movies like maybe like i said
like doctor strange love or
yeah um or something like that i like
strange love that's the closest thing i
can
that's the closest thing i can think of
to it yeah but i so i was reading a
review of it and somebody mentioned
the magic christian which wasn't [ __ ]
ringo starr in that i want to say ringo
starr was in that
um and i was like yeah something like
that and if you're into like british
humor because it's it has kind of like a
british
kind of dry sensibility to it it's like
yeah it's much much drier
than a than an american comedy would be
yeah all right so
uh we done yeah we're done all right all
right so we will be back
tomorrow probably tomorrow we're going
to do a food show yeah yeah we can do
that we're going to talk about curry
tomorrow
okay and uh so yeah thanks everybody for
dropping by as usual
and we'll be back tomorrow at 3 p.m so
have a good rest of your weekend
and we'll see you tomorrow bye